who will form germany's next ruling  coalition  that's the question on everybody's lips  here  if the cdu can't govern a loan they  should go with the greens  cdu spd because nothing else will last  long  voters clearly chose angela merkel we  can't have a coalition between the left  the spd and the greens  a grand coalition between the cdu and  sbd is the most popular choice  48 percent want to see that 18 want the  cdu and the greens to work together  while just 16 percent want an sbd left  green coalition  if the cdu can work with the spd then  maybe something good could come from  that  i think it's crucial for the other  parties if the two biggest parties are  together the rest won't have much of a  say  a grand coalition would bring the  greatest progress it's the best way to  tie the interests of the majority  together  it could take months until the  negotiations are completed  you